From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC
[ Silencio ]
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon,
my name is Georgette Dorn
and I'm the Chief of
the Hispanic Division.
It is a great pleasure to
welcome here Carmen Alicia Morales
from Puerto Rico.
And I have met her several years ago
when we dedicated the
[Spanish?] in Maryland.
I hate to say how many
years ago, many, many.
And it is a great pleasure
to introduce her daughter,
Anna Morales, Anna Deeny
Morales, who is a dear friend.
She's a professor at Georgetown
University at the Center
for Latin American Studies.
She's a graduate of University of
California, Berkley and the author
of many translation [inaudible] and
other Latin American writers like,
[Spanish names?] and many others.
And she will introduce her wonderful
mother, [inaudible] family.
Thank you.
[ Aplausos ]
[ Silencio ]
>> Anna Deeny Morales: I
guess I can begin in English.
It's a huge pleasure to be here.
I remember coming as a little
girl, many, many, many times,
over several years, to
the Library of Congress,
first to hear my mom performing.
And then when I got into high
school, and you could sneak in,
we would change our uniforms because
you couldn't get in at that time
as a high school student.
So we would change into
lay clothing and come in
and use the books at the library.
So it's a real pleasure
to be here today.
And thank you Georgette and
Thalia for organizing this event.
Bienvenidos a la presentación
del libro, ¿me escuchan bien?
Ok. "Isabel la Católica,
influencia en Puerto Rico",
por Carmen Alicia Morales.
Carmen Alicia Morales nació en
el 1945 en Santurce, Puerto Rico.
Obtuvo su bachillerato en
Teatro y Literatura Inglesa,
de la universidad de Puerto
Rico y una Maestría en Teatro,
de la Universidad Católica
en Washington DC.
Como tantos de tus hermanos
y hermanas, hijas, hijos,
nietas y nietos, primos y vecinos,
aquí se quedó por
más de 50 años.
Aquí se dedicó, bueno
aquí se dedicó,
aquí en Maryland y Washington
DC se dedicó a la enseñanza del
español, que conlleva por supuesto,
la difusión de la
cultura puertorriqueña.
Aquí también, Carmen
Alicia Morales,
empezó a escribir y
a recitar su poesía.
Su obra literaria incluye
"Cundeamores", "Ay, bendito",
"Cangrejeros", "Borrachera
madrigal", "Diario poético",
además de dos obras teatrales,
"Turulete" y "La Reina Isabela".
Durante los últimos 50 años,
Morales se ha dedicado a publicar
y recitar su poesía en decenas de
universidades y festivales
literarios,
a través de los Estados
Unidos y Latino América.
Después de haberse jubilado de
su carrera como maestra de escuela
pública, en el 2009 obtuvo su
doctorado en historia medieval,
en la Universidad de
Valladolid, en España.
Como el Congreso Internacional
de la Lengua Española,
se llevó a cabo este Marzo en
Puerto Rico y yo tuve la oportunidad
de ir a ese Congreso,
se me ocurre preguntar,
¿cuál sería el país
de proveniencia de Carmen
Alicia Morales?
Es decir, ¿de cuál país proviene
una puertorriqueña que vive más de
la mitad de su vida nutriéndose,
si esa sería la palabra,
de otro lenguaje?,
de otros alimentos,
ritmos y estéticas culturales,
de todo lo bueno y lo malo
que se encuentra por acá.
Lo que desarrolla Morales en su obra
poética es que el país por dónde
juegan sus meditaciones, sus
sentimientos y en fin, sus versos,
es el lenguaje mismo y el
origen de ese lenguaje,
no necesariamente de
ella, es Puerto Rico.
Déjenme explicar.
No podemos escoger el
lugar de nacimiento,
ni por dónde nos encuentra
la muerte,
ni por dónde nos llevan las
necesidades económicas o si somos
afortunados en el amor.
Pero sí podemos decidir
participar en un lenguaje,
aunque sea en la distancia,
aunque sea arriesgando el naufragio
que amenaza un país como los
Estados Unidos, que ama el
monolingüismo, la mono cultura;
en fin, el mono ser humanismo.
Aunque los dialectos
puertorriqueños conllevan toda su
historia, tanto sucia, violenta
y vergonzosa, como múltiple,
vasta y bella, es siempre de
ahí, de este momento, de ahora,
de ti y de lo tuyo, en su
maravillosa singularidad.
Carmen Alicia Morales,
si han leído su poesía,
si la han escuchado
recitar, saben esto de ella.
Observa el mundo desde un lenguaje
y ese lenguaje es una decisión,
además de una manera
de ver verbalmente.
Y esa manera verbal, sumamente
sónica, multirítmica, comelona,
silábica, avocálica
y consonántica,
es de Puerto Rico y de su
diáspora, que se encuentra aquí.
Sin embargo, hablar el español
en Puerto Rico también conlleva
enfrentarnos a la complejidad de su
presencia de eso se trata la labor
histórica de Morales,
cuando considera la
influencia de la Reina Isabela,
la Reina Isabela de España en la
isla, no como figura ideológica,
sino como generadora de ciertas
estructuras culturales y simbólicas
que forman parte de una
herencia lingüística.
Así que pensar de manera
histórica para Morales,
implica el reconocimiento de
un lenguaje y de una cultura,
tanto a través de su maravillosa
sonoridad y capacidades productoras,
como a través de su ferocidad.
Por eso, estudiar a la Reina
Isabela en Puerto Rico,
de cierta manera significa también
lamentar el español que atraviesa
por estas zonas.
Les presento a mi mamá,
Carmen Alicia Morales.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: Quiero
darles las gracias a todos ustedes,
que han venido en la tarde de hoy.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Maestra, al fin.
Quiero darle las gracias a todos
ustedes que han venido en la tarde
de hoy, en especial a las
personas a cargo de hacer toda la
manifestación de la Biblioteca
del Congreso, a Thalía Guzmán,
la doctora Thalía Guzmán, a
la profesora Georgette Dorn,
por habernos recibido en esta tarde
y hacer posible esta presentación
de este libro.
Y por supuesto, en
especial a mi hija también,
que tiene la delicadeza
de presentarme,
de conocerme y de honrarme
con su presencia esta tarde.
Comencé las investigaciones
sobre Isabel la Católica en esta
biblioteca, en esta sub
biblioteca de Washington DC.
En 1991, en febrero de 1991,
solamente se encontraba en
la Biblioteca del Congreso,
un libro de importancia para la vida
de la reina Isabel la Católica.
Fue escrito por Antonio
Rumeu de Armas.
"Itinerario de los
Reyes Católicos".
Para mí en ese momento
lejana de toda la posibilidad,
porque no me encontraba
atada a ninguna universidad,
me encontraba trabajando en una
escuela intermedia en Potomac,
fue esencial, fue importantísimo
encontrar ese libro y algunos otros,
porque todavía no había empezado
el boom del reconocimiento de 1992,
con Isabel la Católica,
porque es en 1992,
el período en el cual se crea una
importancia de 500 años de venida
de los españoles al
Nuevo Mundo, entonces,
es en esa coyuntura que yo decidí,
buscando un personaje teatral,
empezar a escribir sobre la
Reina Isabel la Católica,
con los libros que
encontré en esta biblioteca.
Así continué y mientras me
encontraba escribiendo sobre esta
reina, ya llevo 25 años
investigando sobre su vida,
mientras me encontraba
haciendo esa labor,
empecé a encontrar rasgos
culturales dentro de Puerto Rico,
que yo decía, ¡Dios Mío,
pero si esto viene directamente
de la monarquía de esta reina!
Así que eso, eventualmente, en un
tercer libro sobre esta monarquía,
me lleva a escribir de
unos ensayos que surgen,
esto me lleva a escribir
y a publicar el libro
"Influencia en Puerto Rico".
Esta pintura que están
viendo en este primer cuadro,
se encuentra en el
Museo de San Juan.
Esta pintura fue hecha para el
quincentenario de su nacimiento,
en 1951.
Ella nació el 22 de abril de 1451
y este cuadro lo pinta Juan Antonio
Morales, es un pintor vallisoletano,
de casualidad lleva mi apellido y,
entonces, Juan Antonio Morales
trabajó para la Casa de la Moneda,
en Madrid, por muchos años.
Esta cara de la Reina Isabel
está basada en otro cuadro,
que es anónimo, de una
segunda mitad del Siglo XV.
Se llama "La virgen de la mosca".
Aquí, a la derecha, apuntando
una línea en un libro,
se encuentra la reina,
lo que se cree, ¿no?,
dentro de la imaginaría isabelina,
que es posiblemente la Reina Isabel,
porque así es como ella está
descrita en las crónicas,
con pelo rubio y ojos pardos.
Entonces, se llama "La virgen de
la mosca", porque evidentemente,
después de esta pintura
del Siglo XV,
en algún momento en el Siglo XVI,
se concibe pintar en el lienzo
rojo que vemos en el centro,
una pequeña mosca y
por eso se le ha llamado
"La virgen de la mosca" y eso fue,
debido a que este cuadro se
encuentra en el Museo de San Juan,
se me ofrece, mientras yo me
encontraba haciendo este libro,
me lo ofrece el curador del museo,
para que lo utilice en este libro,
dado que se encuentra en
la isla de Puerto Rico.
Ahora, vamos a examinar el nombre
de San Juan en la vida de Isabel la
Católica, el nombre de Juan
se expresa en su vida familiar
constantemente, porque Isabel la
Católica viene de un padre que fue
Juan II de Castilla.
Y ella viene-- Es además bisnieta
directa de Juan I de Portugal.
Su ascendencia con
Juan es tan importante,
que ella nombra dos de sus hijos, el
príncipe Juan y la infanta Juana,
o sea, que en una familia,
yo examiné a ver si esto era común
durante ese período y no encontré
otra familia.
Saben que, proyecto y un período
en el cual nacían muchos hijos.
Yo no encontré esta casualidad
en más ninguna otra familia
que estudié.
También se encontraban
del lado del rey Fernando,
la madre del Rey Fernando,
se llamaba Juana,
Juana Enríquez y su padre se
llamaba Juan II de Aragón.
Así es que por ambos
lados de la familia,
el nombre de Juan era importante.
En la parte religiosa, mucho antes
de la reina tener sus hijos o
casarse con Fernando, es a
San Juan a quién ella escoge,
a San Juan Evangelista, para
su propio emblema, en 1468,
que ahora se los voy a
enseñar y en arquitectura,
el monasterio más importante
que construye esta mujer,
que se construye en 1479,
el Monasterio Franciscano
San Juan de los Reyes,
que se encuentra en Toledo, fue
dedicado a San Juan Bautista.
Una vez más, mire,
aquí les voy a enseñar.
Aquí está, este fue el
emblema original de la reina,
cuando era princesa, dice:
"Y yo la princesa-- ".
O sea, mucho antes de la
construcción de este emblema que
vemos más adelante, con el yugo y
las flechas y el nombre de Fernando.
Aquí está San Juan de
los Reyes, en Toledo,
esta es la parte de adentro y
aquí también quiero que observen,
que esto es un ejemplo de
arquitectura isabelina,
porque noten todos los bordes de la
parte de arriba y los adornos en los
arcos de las ventanas.
Muy típico.
El segundo viaje de Colón.
Entonces, ¿cómo llega exactamente?
Eso es la importancia que tiene ese
nombre en la vida de esta mujer,
el nombre de Juan.
Ahora, ¿cómo llega y por qué
llega Colón a nombrar la isla
San Juan?
Porque en una primera instancia,
la isla es nombrada San Juan.
Bueno, pues, aquí le
saqué directamente,
para que vieran el trozo de cita
del cual yo saqué y otra vez más,
Colón enfatiza que esta isla es
parecida a la isla de Sicilia,
la isla de Sicilia tiene mucha
relevancia en la vida de Isabel la
Católica, porque cuando
Fernando se casa con ella,
es la isla de Sicilia, lo
que él lleva en la dote,
para que se mantengan
económicamente.
Así es que, atento y
conocedor de este detalle,
Colón lo nombra cuando dedica
a la isla de Puerto Rico,
a San Juan Bautista, dice
que es parecida al reino,
a la isla de Sicilia.
Y aquí, y hay otra cosa más,
entonces, si todavía no menciono,
en la próxima línea de Colón,
también la considero muy relevante.
Colón sabía que Isabel
la Católica,
una de las encomiendas importantes
que no está mencionada en las
capitulaciones de Santa Fe.
Colón sabía que Isabel la
Católica venía de un área
agrícola, que para
Isabel la Católica,
aunque no fuera implícitamente
escrito,
era importante la agricultura.
Y eso está, eso es parte de una
política ambiental de la reina a
través de toda su vida.
La reina está enterrada
en un hábito franciscano.
Su padre, el Rey Juan II de Castilla
fue enterrado en hábito franciscano
y su abuelo Enrique III fue
enterrado en hábito franciscano y
ella pide ser enterrada, no
solamente en hábito franciscano,
sino en un monasterio franciscano
que ella manda a construir.
Noten que a pesar de que otro
monasterio se llama San Juan de los
Reyes, es un monasterio franciscano,
dedicado a San Juan Bautista.
¿Y qué pasa con San Francisco?
Bueno, es que San Francisco es el
primer ambientalista de Europa,
Siglo XIII.
Y esta reina era dedicada a este
Santo, a través de toda su vida,
además que son franciscanos los que
la educan en la Villa de Arévalo
donde ella vivía.
Noten qué es lo que dice ella
sobre la isla de San Juan Bautista:
"Tiene montañas, tiene
árboles muy grandes",
dice que las tierras
están labradas y sembradas.
Y aquí Colón va directamente
a lo que la reina quería oír,
porque ella quería oír eso,
de que iba a haber la posibilidad
de mantenerse alimenticiamente.
Vamos entonces, al banderín.
Paso ahora y les hablo un poquito.
El libro está hecho de ensayos,
así es que hay muchos temas y
yo escogí algunos temas de los
diferentes ensayos que yo creía que
más les podía agradar o interesar.
El banderín que se encuentra
empuñado por el cordero que aparece
en el emblema de San Juan, que es
entregado a la isla de Puerto Rico,
porque ya todavía,
todavía se estaba llamando,
todavía se estaba
llamando San Juan.
Es más adelante cuando se empiezan
a ver unos cambios y se queda,
entonces, después de la
fundación del islote,
se queda aquel como San Juan y acá
se queda la isla como Puerto Rico.
Pero este banderín es
empuñado por Pelayo,
el gran guerrero que después se
convierte en rey de Asturias en el
año 718.
Este banderín es más
adelante utilizado,
se llama el Banderín de Jerusalén,
se llama la Bandera de Jerusalén y
es utilizado por las cruzadas entre
el Siglo IX y el Siglo XI, porque
este fue un escudo de armas,
para utilizarse belicosamente.
En cuanto al cordero, ¿cuándo es
primeramente que aparece el cordero?
Pues miren, después de
una extensa búsqueda,
yo encontré que la primera vez
que aparece el cordero reflejado en
imaginería cristiana, fue en
el Siglo IV después de Cristo,
en el Baptisterio San
Juan de Letrán, en Roma,
que fue construido por
el emperador Constantino.
Y lo que simboliza y la razón por
la cual el emperador lo manda a
poner en este Baptisterio, que es
el área más importante de esta,
de esta catedral donde se construye,
es porque él lo pone
representando renacimiento.
Y la primera vez que es
expresado, es expresado de pie.
Les he traído este
otro cordero, este otro,
que me lo acabo de
encontrar en Lisboa, Portugal.
Y este fue hecho, este fue hecho
para el convento Madre de Deus,
en 1509.
O sea, nuestro escudo es
entregado en 1511 y en 1509,
se encuentra este emblema, esta
imaginería en este otro convento.
Noten que es muy parecido al
nuestro, tiene el mismo banderín,
el cordero echado, en nuestro
emblema el cordero originalmente fue
concebido en color gris,
el fondo en color verde.
¡Ah! Y hay algo que no aparece en
nuestro emblema en el día de hoy.
Es el libro y se están refiriendo
al libro de los siete sellos y estos
siete sellos no necesariamente
se refieren al Apocalipsis.
Estos sellos, según
yo he analizado,
estos siete sellos pertenecen
a los siete sellos romanos,
que eran exigidos legalmente para
cerrar pergaminos legales en Roma.
Entonces, los personajes
que llegan a Puerto Rico,
los primeros tres personajes
importantes que llegan a
nuestra isla.
Había algo en común que
tenían estos tres personajes,
independientemente de
su educación y de--
Estos tres personajes
venían de áreas de huertos,
agricultura y siembras.
Cristóbal Colón, si la teoría es
que Cristóbal Colón es genovés,
Cristóbal Colón no
nació en puerto,
Cristóbal Colón nació tierra
adentro y una de las teorías es que
viene de familia agrícola.
Por eso también, recuerden qué
es lo primero que le describe a la
reina sobre la isla de San Juan.
Y más adelante le escribe otra
carta extensa sobre la isla de Santo
Domingo, otra vez hablando sobre la
agricultura y los logros agrícolas
dentro de la isla de Santo Domingo.
Juan Ponce de León y Alonso Manso
vienen del área que se llama Tierra
de Campos.
Juan Ponce de León es Santervás.
Hoy en día es parte del norte
de la provincia de Valladolid,
pero en este momento,
eso era considerado parte
del sur de Valencia.
Alonso Manso viene de Becerril
de Campos, que está en Valencia.
En una segunda mitad del Siglo XV,
Valencia era el área agrícola
más productiva de toda Castilla.
Aquí está la carta
de Colón, 1493,
miren todo lo que este
hombre le dice.
Esta es una descripción sobre,
una carta completa; o sea,
esto está fuera de
los diarios de Colón.
Es una carta completa,
expresando todo lo que agricultura,
agrícolamente contiene la isla de
Santo Domingo y la razón por la
cual esa isla va a ser muy
fructífera para esta colonización
y conquista.
Así es Tierra de Campos,
son humedales,
con un piar de pájaros increíbles.
Específicamente Madrigal, donde
nació Isabel la Católica,
la Villa de Madrigal, en La Moraña,
contiene un 2% de la
población acuática del mundo;
hace 15 años atrás, cuando
yo me encontraba haciendo la
investigación sobre Madrigal.
Eso quiere decir que si hace 15
años atrás contenía un 2% de las
especies acuáticas del mundo,
quiere decir que 500 años atrás,
tiene que haber tenido una
población de aves acuáticas
muchísimo más alta.
Yo he dormido varias veces
en esa Villa, el piar,
debido a los humedales
que quedan en esa Villa,
el piar de la mañana parece
un canto llano gregoriano,
qué bello que es.
Es continúo, no oíste un pajarito,
no, es todo un canto de pájaros.
Ahora vamos a la carta de Ponce
de León, sobre la agricultura,
que escribe Ponce de León a
Nicolás de Ovando en 1508,
cuando Nicolás de Ovando le
comunica que se ha decidido que
tiene que dejar su hacienda en
Higüey e irse a gobernar la isla
de Puerto Rico, no estaba feliz,
no estaba feliz tampoco
cuando los vecinos deciden,
empiezan a decidir en 1515 que
se quieren mudar de Caparra a un
islote, no se quiere mudar porque
este hombre lo que le gustaba era
la agricultura.
Miren lo que le dice, a él no
le importa la casa en Higüey;
a él a lo que le importa es que él
quiere dejar encomendados para la
sustentación de la labranza
y crianza que en ella tengo.
Otra vez, la importancia de su
conoco, la importancia de su huerto.
Primer obispo del Nuevo
Mundo, Alonso Manso,
llega a Puerto Rico originalmente
el 25 de diciembre de 1512.
Se va para buscar ayuda del
Rey Fernando, el rey muere,
él se ve en 1515,
en el Camino 1516,
el Rey Fernando muere y este
hombre no obtiene ayuda económica.
Juan Diego de Deza que había
sido su amigo, otro cura,
Fray Diego de Deza, que se
encontraba en Sevilla, le dice:
"Mira, no tenemos dinero para
mandarte obispo otra vez,
pero tenemos dinero para
enviarte como inquisidor".
Y lo mandan como inquisidor.
Regresa a Puerto Rico en 1519,
otra vez como primer obispo del
Nuevo Mundo y primer inquisidor del
Nuevo Mundo.
Yo estoy segura, viniendo este
hombre de Becerril de Campos,
después de haber visitado
Becerril de Campos,
que hasta la iglesia de Becerril de
Campos fue utilizada en el Siglo XV
para mantener parte del
grano de Becerril de Campos,
porque no daban abasto con
las cosechas que los rodeaban,
yo estoy segura que en lo que es hoy
en día el estacionamiento del Hotel
el Convento, en los predios de la
catedral de San Juan en Puerto Rico,
existió un huerto lleno de árboles
frutales, hierbas de especias,
lechuga y cultivos necesarios para
la sobrevivencia de la pequeña
comunidad que se muda
al islote en 1521.
La política ambiental de
Isabel la Católica es extensa.
Cuando Isabel la Católica entra en
la Alhambra el 2 de enero de 1493,
¿ustedes saben lo primero que hizo?
Ella no se preocupó
de recoger el oro,
ella no se preocupó de ordenanzas
para que se portaran bien y
cristianizar a todo el mundo.
Cuando Isabel la Católica
entró en la Alhambra,
lo primero que hizo fue un protocolo
para renovar la acequia real y
renovar las fuentes, porque
todo había sido destruido.
O sea, cuando se abandona
la Alhambra,
el palacio queda en
completa destrucción.
Así es que inmediatamente,
lo que ella-- ¡Ah!
Y sembró 140 naranjales,
140 árboles de china.
Porque, a pesar de que nos
imaginamos de que esas chinas,
esos árboles de china han estado
toda la vida en Granada y en la
Alhambra, eso no estaba ahí, eso
lo manda a sembrar la reina Isabel,
porque a ella le gustaban
las chinas, igual que a mí.
Así que esta es la razón
por la cual todo eso,
más adelante se encontraba
sembrado.
¿Qué comían?
Si estamos hablando de agricultura
y siembra todo el tiempo,
¿qué se comía en
la casa isabelina?
Pues miren, yo he encontrado
recetas de huevos rellenos,
que se comen en Puerto
Rico hoy en día,
exactamente salpicaditos por
paprika, se sacan, se majan,
se le hace una salsita y
se vuelven y se-- Igualito.
Almojábana, les encantaban
las almojábanas.
Pastelón de amarillo, excepto
que no tenían amarillo,
nosotros lo convertimos,
como no teníamos papas,
ellos lo hacían de diferente,
otras cosas que tenían,
porque la papa viene
de Perú, pero tenían,
hay constancia de que había una
cosa que se llamaba pastelón y que
la hacían o de arroz o de lo que
podían encontrar y se rellenaba con
carne molida, igual que lo que se
está comiendo hoy día en Puerto
Rico, el pastelón de amarillo es
una reminiscencia de la casa de una
monarquía isabelina.
Miren. Ustedes quizás ven, vemos el
algodón de azúcar y en qué color
se vende todavía, color rosa.
¿Ustedes saben por qué?
Porque en las cuentas del
tesorero de la casa isabelina,
las cuentas de Gonzalo de Baeza,
el dulce preferido del príncipe
Juan era el algodón de azúcar.
¿Saben por qué es hasta
hoy en día color de rosa?
Porque la costumbre era
añadirle rosas de pétalos rojos,
para que saliera en
tonos de rosa o rojo.
Y lo otro, el dulce de membrillo,
se convirtió en pasta de guayaba,
señores, es la misma
receta de la casa isabelina.
Aparece en todas sus cuentas.
Y se lo comían con queso,
igualito que nosotros.
Al encontrarme todas estas recetas,
o sea, según fue los 25 años,
según iba progresando
mis investigaciones,
pues yo tenía que escribir esto,
yo tenía que comunicar al
pueblo puertorriqueño, miren,
todo esto no solamente
viene de España,
esto viene de una casa isabelina.
Estos fueron manjares servidos
en una mesa de una reina.
Puerto Rico tiene ahora mismo dos
lugares en el viejo San Juan que
están llenos de documentación
isabelina.
Tenemos el Museo del Mar,
que lo funda el señor Busto,
español que llega a
la isla de Puerto Rico,
un comerciante en el
mismo viejo San Juan,
que llega a la isla de Puerto Rico
y empieza a comprar piezas para este
museo y entre las piezas
que tenemos es esta moneda,
que valía 12 escudos, es la Seca
de Sevilla, o sea, vino de Sevilla.
En algún momento un puertorriqueño
le hizo un hueco y se la colgó del
cuello, pero esto viene [risas],
esto se hizo en el Siglo XV,
segunda mitad del Siglo XV, durante
la administración isabelina,
es de oro puro, 22
quilates, señores.
Y esto se encontró en un yacimiento
arqueológico en la isla y se
encuentra en el Museo del Mar,
junto con dos o tres cartas de
la monarquía isabelina que yo he
mandado a traducir y se
encuentran en ese libro.
Hay otro lugar en que se encuentran,
se encuentra una gran colección de
libros de la monarquía isabelina y
se llama La Casa del Libro.
Se encuentran poemarios de Juan de
Mena, que fue poeta de la Corte.
Se encuentra un protocolo
educacional,
escrito [tos] -- Perdón.
Por Fray Hernando de Talavera,
que fue el confesor de la reina,
ese fue escrito en 1496 y se
llama "Caída de Príncipes".
Este protocolo fue escrito cuando
se casa el príncipe Juan con la
princesa Margarita de Austria.
Y se encuentra una colección
además de libros incunables que
fueron escritos y aprobados por
la reina para ser publicados.
Yo les quiero dar las gracias por
estar aquí conmigo esta tarde.
Esta soy yo.
La foto la toma mi esposo, Federico,
que se encuentra aquí conmigo y
me acompaña en estas aventuras por
todos estos lugares que yo me voy.
Y ahora, con mucho gusto,
¿cuánto tiempo tenemos?
>> Georgette Dorn:
Tenemos bastante tiempo.
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: Sí pues,
entonces ahora quiero
abrir la sala a preguntas.
Pero antes, antes de
Se encuentra aquí con nosotros
el Señor Erick Cardona,
el Señor Erick Cardona es un
puertorriqueño residente de
Virginia, que se ha
dedicado a escudriñar,
a investigar la historia
y es su pasión.
Cuando yo me encontraba
trabajando en este libro,
buscando el documento original
del emblema de Puerto Rico,
yo estaba viajando, estaba entre
Puerto Rico y como siempre,
en un lado y otro y no
encontraba este documento.
Y el Señor Erick Cardona,
que se encuentra aquí
entre nosotros esta tarde,
tuvo la amabilidad de encontrar
el documento, la referencia,
mandármelo por correo electrónico,
para que yo pudiera entonces
encontrar un analista y traductor de
paleografía que comprendiera
la letra de las personas que
escribieron el documento
del emblema de Puerto Rico.
Y eso se tradujo en Puerto Rico,
perdió gracias públicamente,
porque estos pequeños encuentros
de Facebook ayudan muchísimo.
Y ahora abro para preguntas.
Dígame.
>> ¿Dónde está el Museo del Mar?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: ¿Dónde
se encuentra el Museo del Mar?
Buenísima pregunta.
El Museo del Mar se encuentra
en la calle San Francisco a mano
izquierda, según usted
entra, en el viejo San Juan,
en la calle San Francisco,
casi frente por frente a una de las
puertas de la iglesia San Francisco.
Apenas sí se ve, pertenece a un
edificio y antes de llegar a la
placita que se llamaba la
Placita de la Barandilla,
que ahora se llama la
Plaza de San Francisco.
>> ¿Y cuándo iniciaron ese museo?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: Pues mire,
este museo tiene como
un año y pico,
el curador es un joven español
de nombre Manuel Minero,
que llega a la isla de Puerto
Rico en una de las regatas.
Han venido, a Puerto Rico vienen
constantemente naves de diferentes
parte del mundo, con gente
interesantísima y este joven,
pues esta era su pasión, estudiar
estos barcos de ese siglo y se ha
quedado y ha hecho una
gran contribución,
no solamente al Museo del Mar,
porque él lo ha catalogado,
sino que también a la Asociación
de Historia del Viejo San Juan que
yo he fundado y realizamos congresos
y él ha hecho unas contribuciones
sobre las naves que llegaron
a Puerto Rico el Siglo XVI.
¿Alguna otra pregunta?
>> ¿Dónde es eso?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Pues estamos en Segovia.
Aquí podemos ver en el fondo,
la torre prominente es
la catedral de Segovia,
que por cierto es construida,
es casi reciente,
porque es construida
en el Siglo XVI,
es posterior al período
isabelino, así es que--
Y la foto la tomó mi esposo
y esta es una de mis visitas
investigativas, por
ahí por Segovia.
Dígame.
>> ¿Hay un esfuerzo académico
por entender de dónde surgió
Cristóbal Colón?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Bueno, existen--
Yo no diría que un
esfuerzo, ¿verdad?,
de parte de ningún
grupo de estudiosos,
pero sí existen una serie
de teorías muy interesantes,
que han sido desarrolladas por
diferentes académicos o estudiosos
de diferentes áreas.
Está la teoría de que
él nació en Galicia,
está la teoría de
que él es catalán,
está la teoría de que él nació
en Mallorca, está la teoría--
Entonces, porque es una teoría de
que él era genovés, son teorías.
Así es que pues hay diferentes
posibilidades de estudio.
Yo sé que la próxima pregunta
va a ser y usted, ¿qué cree?
¿Cuál es?
[Risas]. Bueno, pues
yo las he leído todas.
Es una decisión muy difícil,
porque se necesitaría ahondar más
en la documentación de los diarios,
todas las-- Todo el epistolario
colombino y yo no tengo el tiempo de
hacer ese tipo de investigación.
Yo estoy dedicada a esta monarquía
y ya me encuentro realizando otro
estudio que me lleva de la
mano a otra, a otra ideología.
Pero por lo bajito, yo creo que
él era catalán, ¿sí o no?
Yo creo que él era catalán,
pero eso no se lo diga
a nadie públicamente,
que Carmen Alicia Morales no lo
dijo, que de aquí no salga [risas].
Eso no lo pueden compartir, no.
Yo creo que él era catalán,
porque yo leí un estudio de que la
sintaxis de sus oraciones revelan
esa posibilidad, eso es número uno.
No solamente creo que era catalán,
yo creo que él era judío, además.
Y que entonces-- Pero lo que pasa
es que esos estudios tienen que ser
hechos por lingüistas catalanes.
Necesitamos lingüistas catalanes
dedicados al estudio lingüístico
de la posibilidad de la sintaxis y
el vocabulario que él utiliza en
sus epistolarios y documentos,
porque no se puede contar por
los diarios, con los diarios,
porque ese día no es
completo de Cristóbal Colón.
Y número dos, también he leído
sobre una posible imaginería que
aparece en las cartas escrita
a su hijo Diego Colón,
que podrían ser reminiscencia
de símbolos judíos.
Así es que-- También creo que
él tiene que haber venido de una
familia con cierta
relevancia social y cultural,
porque la mujer con la cual él
se casa en Portugal venía de la
familia Noronha y esa familia,
la tía de la esposa
de Cristóbal Colón,
que ese detalle aparece en mi
libro, la tía de la esposa, sí,
la tía de la esposa de Cristóbal
Colón estuvo casada con el
bisabuelo de Isabel la
Católica, increíble, ¿no?
El rey Juan I de Portugal
tuvo un hijo ilegítimo que se
llamó Alfonso.
Ese hijo ilegítimo es padre de
la abuela que se llamó Isabel de
Barceló, que es la abuela de Isabel
la Católica y es la que la cría.
Y este hombre se convierte,
este Alfonso,
pertenece a la familia más
poderosa y más rica de Portugal.
Este hombre era lo suficientemente
astuto y poderoso para retar los
hijos de sus propios hermanos que
quedan cuando muere el rey Juan I
de Portugal.
Y en unas segundas nupcias, después
que muere su primera esposa,
él se casa con esta mujer que
está, el nombre está en el libro,
ahora se me escapa el
primer nombre de ella,
pero su apellido era Noronha y
esta era la tía de la esposa de
Cristóbal Colón.
Así es que Cristóbal Colón
no solamente llega, o sea,
no cae del aire, no llega nada más
que a través de estos curitas,
en un monasterio.
Cristóbal Colón traía
sus garras políticas.
Y un padre de cierta
posición social y cultural,
como era el Padre de
la esposa de Colón,
no hubiera permitido que esa
hija se casara con ese hombre,
a menos que ese hombre no
hubiera validado sus raíces,
su lugar social y su
cultura, ¿comprende?
Así es que yo-- o sea, yo creo que
él tiene que haber venido de alguna
familia de alguna importancia.
>> Recuerdo que una vez fui a una
conferencia en la cual la exponente
habló de que algunas de las
cartas de Colón estaban escritas
en ladino.
¿Has pensado en eso?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: No,
eso no es lo que decía, no.
Bueno, un momento, vamos atrás.
La persona, la catedrática en
cuestión que escribió el libro,
es la profesora Estela Irizarry,
catedrática de la
Universidad de Georgetown.
Las cartas en cuestión
fueron analizadas por ella.
Es muy difícil que
la Academia reconozca,
a pesar de su especialidad como
catedrática de temas de literatura
hispanoamericana, a pesar de venir
de raíces judías ella misma,
es muy difícil que una Academia
española reconozca ese análisis,
porque ese análisis tiene que
entrar en un contexto histórico y
no, esas cartas fueron analizadas,
esas además de una carta posterior
que escribe Cristóbal Colón a la
reina Isabel, son analizadas
fuera de contexto histórico,
así que yo no cuento
completamente con,
no me acerco a afianzarme
sobre ese estudio,
para llegar a esa conclusión.
Debido a eso, que su especialidad
no es historia de España,
no es historia medieval de España,
su especialidad no es el ladino que
se estaba escribiendo en el Siglo XV
y no es tampoco ni el catalán,
ni el costumbrismo
sefardí del período.
Así es que yo, o sea, que cada
estudio que leo pues hay que
situarlo dentro de un
contexto académico.
¿Qué opina?
O sea, ¿qué otros libros
ha escrito este profesor,
para entonces poder
llegar a esta conclusión?
¿Y de qué se rodea?
¿Qué estudios están incluidos?
O sea, hay que leer
una bibliografía,
¿y de quién está
hecha esta bibliografía?
Uh-huh.
>> ¿Hay alguna influencia
musulmana?,
cuando Puerto Rico empieza.
Porque tenemos tanta
influencia española musulmana.
¿Hay una influencia que hubiese en
Puerto Rico de la parte musulmana
de España?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Las hermosas almojábanas.
[ Hablan al unísono ]
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: Bueno,
las palabras no podemos
decir las palabras.
Estos ya eran vocablos que habían
sido aceptados y que siguen siendo
aceptados dentro de
una lengua en España.
Así que-- Eso es número uno.
Número dos, yo no me he
especializado en influencia
musulmana, no existe nadie en Puerto
Rico que se haya especializado en
historia musulmana del período.
Porque no solamente
historia musulmana,
es lo que se llama
influencia mudéjar.
No podemos hablar de moros,
no podemos hablar de árabes,
esto no es lo que llega a nosotros.
La invasión del año 711 fue
una complejidad de bereberes,
sarracenos y árabes musulmanes.
Se refleja más la
posibilidad de los árabes,
siempre hablamos de los
árabes, ¿por qué?
Porque el último estandarte que
fue Granada, que se destruye,
esa era la asentación que más
influencia del grupo árabe que
llegó, esa era la asentación
que más influencia tenía.
Pero eran mudéjares.
O sea, yo soy segunda
generación nacida en Puerto Rico,
yo no soy española,
yo soy puertorriqueña.
Esto no, o sea, tienen que hacer
unos estudios bien específicos,
yo no me atrevería a decir
sí o no ni a dar ejemplo,
excepto las almojábanas.
[ Risas ]
>> Dígame, señor.
>> Si aceptamos que tenemos los
restos de Colón en España y no en
Santo Domingo, ¿podríamos hacer
estudio genético y tratar de dar
contestación a la pregunta?
¿Tendremos descendientes de
Colón en España también?
O sea, que se podría usar.
Si, por ejemplo, no
encontramos los genes italianos,
porque nos empezamos a pelear con
los italianos en Estados Unidos,
sería, es posible que
en verdad es catalán,
pero la verdad es que los que
empujan la idea de que es catalán,
son los catalanes.
Yo siempre he tenido ese
problema con esa teoría.
Pero, digo, si uno...
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Ojo, pero yo no soy catalana.
>> [Risas].
Pero cómo apareció esa
casa, yo [inaudible].
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Sí, bueno, mire, sí.
Lo que pasa es esto.
Otra vez entran en
juego las teorías.
Cristóbal Colón murió en 1506.
La Reina Isabel la Católica
murió en noviembre 26 de 1504.
Al morir la Reina Isabel
la Católica,
Castilla es un reino de nadie,
hasta 1506, un par de meses antes,
no entra la reina Juana I de
Castilla con Felipe el Hermoso.
Felipe el Hermoso muere
inmediatamente en 1506.
O sea, Colón muere en Valladolid
definitivamente, sabemos que murió,
porque hay documentación
para comprobar eso,
pero dónde exactamente
está enterrado Colón,
eso está en entredicho.
En Valladolid, yo he visitado
la casa de Colón muchas veces,
porque se encuentra en el centro
de la ciudad de Valladolid,
pero no hay una tumba en
Valladolid directamente,
que se pueda comprobar y no
ha habido interés además.
Hay una cosa que se
llama querer e interés.
Ves, la búsqueda del
estudio del DNA de Cervantes,
pues eso es un estudioso que se
ha dedicado toda su vida a que se
busque y se saquen los restos que se
encuentran en la iglesia de Madrid,
en el convento donde se creía
que él estaba enterrado.
Así es que eso está
bien, bien, bien difícil.
Sí, cómo no.
>> Anunciada Colón,
que es descendiente directa de
Cristóbal Colón cree que está
enterrado en Sevilla,
en la catedral.
La catedral no permite que
abran el catafalco para que se--
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Sí, hay montones.
O sea, otra vez, todo
esto es teoría.
Fíjense, fíjense
bien, estado, 1506,
Castilla no tiene reina ni rey.
Hay una pugna entre Fernando el
Católico y Felipe el Hermoso,
porque Fernando quiere el reino.
Se nombra a Cisneros temporeramente,
para que ocupe un puesto
en lo que entra la reina.
Entra la reina con Felipe el Hermoso
y Felipe el Hermoso muere en Burgos.
Fernando, ¿por qué
Fernando el Católico,
si él no estaba de acuerdo
con la política colombina?
Y él es el que lo manda a apresar.
¿Por qué Fernando el Católico
lo va a enterrar en la Catedral
de Sevilla?
Muere Fernando el Católico en 1516,
no hay dinero para enterrar a nadie.
A Fernando lo llevan hasta Granada,
porque ahí fue que exigió Isabel
la Católica que él tenía que
ser enterrado.
Todavía sigue el reino en veremos,
porque no ha entrado Carlos V.
Carlos V nació en el año 1500.
Fernando muere en 1516.
Carlos V entra en 1517.
O sea, ¿cuándo?
¿Cuándo estos restos?
¿Cuándo se va a construir
ese monumento?
¿Cuándo se va a hacer eso?
¿Cuándo los herederos de Colón
logran empezar a recuperar algo de
lo que Colón había invertido?
Porque Colón había
invertido dinero.
Este viajecito no se hace de las
joyas de Isabel la Católica.
Ella no tenía ni corona
en 1492, ni corona,
hasta la corona estaba empeñada.
Se habían envuelto en
una guerra por 10 años,
en una conquista de Granada.
Entre 1482 y 1492, antes de eso ella
había pasado cinco años peleando
en contra de Portugal, en una guerra
sucesoria para quitarle el trono a
Juana la Beltraneja.
Y antes de eso habían
pasado cinco años,
sus primeros cinco
años de matrimonio,
peleando en contra de su
propio hermano, Enrique IV,
porque él la declara persona
non grata y la persigue.
Isabel la Católica estaba
viviendo derritiendo las velas,
eso aparece en mi primer libro,
derritiendo velas de las iglesias
para poder mantener las propas.
Y gastaba por un tubo y siete
llaves, porque le encantaba,
a ella le encantaba vestir bien.
Y ella utilizaba esa parafernalia de
su vestimenta y de construir esto o
aquello, como construye Santa Fe
en 1491, la Ciudad de Santa Fe,
que la construye como
imaginería para impresionar.
Habría que abrir, yo sé,
yo he leído también sobre
la posibilidad de Sevilla,
pero hay que abrirlo.
>> ¿[Inaudible] detenido
en cárcel, encarcelado?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Sí, pero, vamos-- Señor.
>> Volviendo a Isabel.
Antes de morir, ¿ella sabía
que esto no era India y que
era América?
O sea, que era otro continente,
¿o todavía no sabía?
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: Mire, hay
cuatro viajes, hay cuatro viajes.
¿Cómo estamos de tiempo?
>> Georgette Dorn: Puede
contestar esta pregunta.
>> Carmen Alicia Morales: Ok, bien.
Mire, hay cuatro viajes y se
queda en las islas del Caribe.
Hay cuatro viajes, el cuarto viaje,
apenas toca entre el
norte de Venezuela,
apenas toca tierra por esa área.
No había nada, no se
había encontrado nada.
Este--
>> O sea, que ella
murió sin saber--
>> Carmen Alicia Morales:
Hay un parrafito en el
testamento de Isabel la Católica--
Miren, yo creo que en Amazon hay
copias de un libro que se llama
"Análisis del testamento
de Isabel la Católica",
en el cual aparece el
documento, por supuesto,
traducido de la paleografía.
Lo que existe en el testamento de
Isabel y no me acuerdo si yo en mi
primer libro sobre Isabel,
que es una Sico biografía,
yo no me acuerdo-- Va a tener
que esperar mi próximo libro.
[ Risas ]
>> Ruta biográfica, ese es uno
de los temas que voy a tocar.
Bueno, ya yo creo que
hemos llegado a un final.
Traje algunos libros
aquí para firmar.
Traje otros de los libros
de mi época previa como
escritora literata.
Doy las gracias una vez más y me
despido de ustedes y estaré aquí,
el que se quiera acercar y
guste de cualquier libro.
>> Georgette Dorn: Muy bien.
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.